ضبابيه المشهد في السودان التي يسهم فيها
بشكل كبير دخان القذائف تنبع من سيل
الاخبار المضلله والكاذبه انتصارات اعلن
عنها الطرفان وصفت بالهشه حينا وبالكاذبه
احيانا دون معرفه الجانب المحق لكن
المعلوم ان المعارك تتركز في هذه المناطق
اي العاصمه الخرطوم اندرمان
ومروي الخرطوم مهد المواجهه المسلحه ان صح
التعبير شهدت اشتعال الشراره الاولى ففيها
تتمركز المواقع الاستراتيجيه والحيويه
التي يتنازع الجيش وقوات دعم السريع سيطر
عليها
الاشتباكات احتدمت على تخوم القصر
الجمهوري ومقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه وقياده قوات الدعم السريعه اضافه
الى مطارات عسكريه ومدنيه لكن التركيز كان
على محيط القياده العامه للمقر اهميه
مركزيه لوقوعه وسط العاصمه فهو يتكون من
خمسه ابنيه ويضم وزاره الدفاع وقيادات
القوات البريه والبحريه والجويه
والاستخبارات العسكريه ما يعني ان الالمام
بكافه الجوانب العسكريه والامنيه في
السودان في جنوب الخرطوم وتحديدا قاعده
النجوم الجويه اظهرت فيديوهات احراق قوات
الدعم السريع لعدد من مروحيات الجيش
السوداني
الى مطار الخرطوم الان الذي يشكل محور
تصادم اعلامي من الجهتين واخر الروايات
تتحدث عن سيطره قوات حماتي قوات الدعم
السريع عليه مع استمرار الاشتباكات من وسط
السودان الى شماله ومطار اخر يشهد احتداما
للمعارك وهو مطار مروي الجيش اعلن قبل
ساعات سيطرته على غالبيته مع انسحاب اعداد
كبيره من قوات حمايه
ياتي ذلك في وقت تتواصل فيه عمليات الكر
والفر في مدينه ام درمان شبكات عنيفه مع
تحليق مستمر للطيران الحربي في سمائها
[موسيقى]
في فرن واحد لا مويه لا كهرباء طبعا
الظروف صعبه يعني
اربع يوم ما نايمين
كلهم لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات